is a very significant blow to the
already damaged
authority of the prime minister it
confirms that he's
too weak to discharge the basic
functions of government
these public health measures would not
have gone through if labor hadn't shown
the leadership that the prime minister
failed to show by voting in the public
interest that's what we did and it was
because of our votes that these measures
went through
are you calling on the prime minister to
resign the prime minister needs to take
a long long hard look at himself and ask
himself whether he has the authority to
take this country through the pandemic
this is a very significant blow for him
do you have anything to say to
conservative rebels
i do
and i say that they should act in the
public interest in the pandemic
the labour party that i lead will act in
the public interest these public health
measures were necessary that's why we
voted in the public interest to ensure
they become
law and it would not have happened if we
hadn't voted for them this evening you
say conservative mps should act in the
public interest are you therefore
encouraging conserved rebels to hand in
letters to the 1922 committee well i
think it's very important to understand
how deep the breach of trust is between
the prime minister and his own
party he has an 80-seat majority and
he's just had you know 90 or 100 of his
own mps voting against him on a
three-line whip that's a significant
blow to the authority of the prime
minister
just
when we need
decisive decisions in this pandemic it's
the worst possible leader at the worst
possible time
so to be clear you think the
conservative rebels should try and get
rid of the prime minister well the prime
minister needs to ask himself the
question whether he has the authority to
lead this country through this pandemic
why did you vote with the government
could you not have voted against them
and delivered a bigger blow
we voted for these public health
provisions because it was in the public
interest to do so in the middle of a
pandemic
we didn't seek party advantage we acted
in the public interest and the labour
party i leave will always act in the
public interest we've been doing it
through the pandemic we did it again
this evening the prime minister in his
efforts to encourage some conservative
rebels seem to have
implied that further restrictions could
be coming down the line if if if
more wasn't done soon enough do you
think that
more restrictions should be introduced
in the coming weeks well what we've done
is follow the science um and talk to the
government scientists and other experts
and follow these science it was obvious
to me that these measures were necessary
this evening which is why we voted for
them we need to review the evidence um
regularly and see whether further
measures are necessary but whatever
persuasion the prime minister tried with
his mps it evidently didn't work because
of this absolute breach of trust between
the prime minister and his own party a
number of your shadow cabinet ministers
have tested positive for covert and
outset
today how does that make you feel are
you changing the way you're acting does
this change how you think the government
should act well we've followed the rules
and therefore our shadow cabinet meeting
was a zoom meeting
again this morning to ensure that we
didn't require people to come
unnecessarily into the office a number
of shadow cabinet members have
got covered that is you know
hard for them and their families at this
difficult time the point of the
provisions this evening was to try to
ensure the infection rate is kept under
a degree of control
have you changed your christmas plans
well our christmas plans are always very
small we always spend it with our family
and therefore we haven't changed it but
we didn't have elaborate christmas plans
anyway